they were the stupid years what they
were doing was incredible
NAFTA one of the world's worst trade
deals ever I know a couple of others
we've been involved in them too by
erecting tariffs and threatening to tear
up free trade agreements President
Donald Trump has done more to advance
one of the left's longstanding policy
goals than any other modern president
and he also sounds a lot like some of
the Democratic candidates that are
running to unseat him in the next
election Bernie Sanders still brags
about how he opposed the north american
free trade agreement when it was
ratified by Congress in 1994 in 2011 the
Vermont senator even went after the
Smithsonian Institution for selling
Chinese made toys we should not be
selling statues of the founding fathers
of this country have been made in China
from the World Trade Organization
protests in Seattle in 1999 to the 2016
campaign trail the left has
traditionally opposed free trade on the
grounds that it hurts American workers I
hope in fact all of us the board we
begin to focused on rebuilding our
manufacturing sector so that we create
millions of jobs in products made in the
United States but it's Donald Trump who
has made at least some of those dreams
come true we're asking Bernie Sanders
voters to join our movement this creates
a conundrum the Democrats running for
office in 2020 can't say that they like
what Trump is doing but they're also not
really willing to criticize his trade
war your approach to trade with China is
very similar to the president US trade
policy has delivered one punch in the
gut after another Trump and anti trade
Democrats failed to grasp that nations
don't really trade with one another at
all individuals and corporations do and
sometimes those individuals and
corporations want to buy or sell
something to someone in another country
and trade is the source of our wealth
since 1950 international trade boosted
Americans per household income by about
18,000 dollars and the gains flowed
disproportionately to lower-income
households if they can save a nickel by
moving a job to Mexico
don't do it no heartbeat Elizabeth is
absolutely right
anybody here thinks that corporate
America gives one damn about the average
American worker you're mistaken but
American manufacturing jobs peaked at
around 20 million in 1979 that's 15
years before NAFTA until bottoming out
at eleven point four million in 2011 the
reason for that decline isn't shifting
jobs overseas
it's automation manufacturing output has
doubled since the mid 1980s America
makes more stuff than ever our factories
just don't require as many workers as
they once did
even supposedly centrist candidates like
Senator Kamala Harris have shifted into
protectionist mode in an interview with
Jake Tapper in May Harris said she
wouldn't have voted for NAFTA if she'd
been in the Senate when it passed I
believe that we have got to have policy
that better protects American workers
and American industries Harris did
criticized Trump's use of tariffs
calling the president's habit of
conducting trade policy economic policy
foreign policy by tweet irresponsible
but that really drives home my point
Democrats seem happy to criticize trumps
haphazard handling of the trade war but
many of the twenty20 candidates are at
least tacitly endorsing this same
protectionist views even Joe Biden once
a pro trade Democrat is now backing away
from his record for fear of upsetting
the progressive left I would not rejoin
the TTP as it was initially put forward
the Democrats are essentially arguing
that all we need is a more competent
protectionist in the White House I think
Trump gets a gets it wrong in terms of
implementation but there's no way to
correctly implement a policy that stops
individuals from freely exchanging goods
and services just because they live in
different countries thanks to President
Donald Trump Bernie Sanders vision of
restricting our ability to peacefully
trade with one another has become policy
and that's a catastrophe for all
Americans